ces deux coureurs sont les nouveaux
patrons de la petite graine à la
martinique
aujourd'hui encore ils ont étalé toutes
les eaux classe dans le championnat en
ligne seniors et espoirs le jeune élu
bull fait d'une pierre trois coups
victoire d'étape pas au finish si toi de
champion espoir et titre de champion
senior
qu'est ce que ça fait quand on est
champion de martinique
mais ça fait moi le palais moi c'est
quelque chose que et que ça c'est
magnifique pas quelque chose que tout le
monde y resteront portis six mois il
apporte une superbe course également de
michael stanislas le champion signaux
2018 a raté de cheveux un second titre
il misera tout sur le tour en pleine
préparation et c'est comme ça et on va
essayer de peaufiner sa encore pour
arriver en forme pour être une
martinique et essayer de brillantes
cédric eustache qui a longtemps fait la
course en tête va lâcher prise à
quelques kilomètres de l'arrivée sur
crevaison
la prochaine grosse compétition le tour
qui commence dans 20 jours